JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Por qué está la presente audiencia dentro del proceso penal que sigue a
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: ministerio público en contra de María Luisa mamá nichoque por la oficina gestora.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Se ha informado que se ha notificado legalmente a las partes para esta audiencia.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: se consulta Si está presente, el ministerio público.
Miguel Cardozo Fiscal: Buenas tardes, señor Juez Ministerio Público: presente, Miguel Cardoso, para fines de registro.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Buenas tardes, está la parte denunciante de rolando Isaac y Maña segasa
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: parte de.
Rolando Imaña - Crediseguro: Está presente acá con en compañía de mi abogado héctor Tapia.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Eres? ¿qué se llama usted?
Rolando Imaña - Crediseguro: Rolando. Y maña.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Jack Imagnés.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Ya está la entrada. María Luisa Mamá, Nichoque
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: María Luisa, me me ha dicho que está en sala
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: el abogado de la parte imputada
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: como gato que la parte imputada.
ABOG. CRISTHIAN MACHI parte imputada: Buenas tardes.
ABOG. CRISTHIAN MACHI parte imputada: Es abogado y a la señora María Luisa.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Cuando usted está con su patrocinador
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: abogado de la parte imputado, está con la encausada
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: abogado de la parte imputada.
ABOG. CRISTHIAN MACHI parte imputada: Sí, Señor Juez: Ahora, si se le escucha abogado de la parte imputada para fines de registro, Cristan Michael Machicado core con registro. Rpa, 79 320 Cmmj.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Con su defendida.
ABOG. CRISTHIAN MACHI parte imputada: Señor juez. Tengo entendido de que se está conectando en el en este caso, en la en en las celdas, juntamente, estoy coordinando ahora con los familiares de la ahora imputada. No se nos podría dar unos minutitos para poderme comunicar.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Ya es 15 min, abogado como con su audiencia.
ABOG. CRISTHIAN MACHI parte imputada: En estos momentos le informo. Le estoy llamando, señor juez.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Un minuto más tiene para comunicarse.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Mhm.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: La señora María Luisa Amancho, que está en sala
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: María Luisa Choque No me ha dicho que
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: abogado ya se ha comunicado con algún familiar.
ABOG. CRISTHIAN MACHI parte imputada: Y ya me he comunicado, me indican que están ingresando ya a la audiencia, Están en la frente, Entonces solicitaría un poco de paciencia va a disculpar. Señor Juez.
ABOG. CRISTHIAN MACHI parte imputada: hemos coordinado ya hace instantes, pero el tema del del de la administración de las funciones policiales. Un poquito están haciendo retrasar, Entonces está conectándose. Me he comunicado, señor juez, están ya con la parte imputada en ese momento.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Ya está conectada la imputada María Luisa Romani.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: María Luisa, la mani
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: abogado se apresura porque tengo otra audiencia, y como que
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: no así estoy asociado a efecto presencial
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: abogado de la parte imputada.
ABOG. CRISTHIAN MACHI parte imputada: Señor juez, Acabo de también comunicarme. Se voy a hacer
ABOG. CRISTHIAN MACHI parte imputada: que se tome conocimiento de que la parte imputada se encuentra en celdas aprendida en la Feng. Se ve siendo que me he comunicado en estos momentos con los familiares y me di me indican de que se está conectando nada más es un poco, tal vez ambigua. Voy a solicitar si se puede declarar un cuarto intermedio, siendo que se encuentra prendida en celdas. Señor juez.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Bien el ministerio público no está presente, la imputada.
Miguel Cardozo Fiscal: Gracias a la autoridad.
Miguel Cardozo Fiscal: Con la finalidad de no vulnerar derechos y garantías constitucionales, la autoridad. Vamos a solicitar las de programación de la presente audiencia, autoridad y que se combine a la al abogado de la parte imputada para que conecte a su cliente en la próxima audiencia autoridad. Muchas gracias. Con solicitar pública.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: De denunciante.
Dr. Tapia: De acuerdo con lo solicitado por el señor representante del Ministerio público, dejando constancia que no es responsabilidad ni de la autoridad jurisdiccional ni del ministerio público.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Fíjate bien
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: tienen atención a lo puesto por el ministerio público y la parte querellante debido a la inexistencia de la imputada María Luisa Román, Choque, a quien se le ha otorgado más de media hora para que se conecte a la audiencia virtual, por lo que se va a fijar una nueva audiencia para el día de mañana.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Ahora, s 11 y 30 quedando notificados y emplazado, las partes procesales
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: se culmina el abogado de la parte imputada que se constituya celdas donde se encuentra la prendida para con
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: conectarse de manera virtual bajo por 100 de ley.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Siendo esta suspensión única y de exclusiva responsabilidad de la parte encausada.
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: Reitero la fecha para el día de mañana a las 11 y 30,
JUEZ- JUAN CARLOS MONTALBAN: su Secretario, puedes usar la grabación hasta luego las partes.